thank you
well good morning ladies and gentlemen
my name is art Benjamin and I am a
Mathemagician what that means is I
combine my loves of math and magic to do
something I call mathematics but before
I get started with anything mathematical
I thought I'd actually begin with a
magic trick
has nothing to do with math really it's
just a really cool trick but for this
I'll need a volunteer to assist me
someone here I do not know and let's see
okay I do not know you what's your name
John what's your name George let's give
George a nice round of applause one up
here George
now George before we begin I have an
important question have we ever met
before have we discussed anything you
seemed proud of that fact good well then
George I'm going to show you and
everyone here a card trick that has
never been seen before never been seen
before because no one can see the cards
George if you would pick a card any card
at all from the deck just one look at
the cards show it to everyone but do not
let me see it that's important I will
shuffle the rest of the cards so you see
they're not in any particular order
George I'd like you to place the card
back inside the deck but just to make it
interesting turn the card upside down
first up upside down please good notice
all the cards are face up except for
George's which is face down now watch
carefully is this took me years of
practice watch watch watch as I make the
deck of cards disappear from my hands
what too late
that's better reappear inside of this
box a box which only moments ago was
empty trust me
now I realize George which you were
doing a moment ago was just a figment of
your imagination
but what was the card for that brief
second at least that you imagined that
you selected George what card did you
imagine ace of clubs that's amazing
George because you'll notice in this
deck that one card and only one card has
been turned upside down would you be so
kind as to show everyone the upside down
card the ace of clubs and let's give
George a nice round of applause thank
you very much
all right well while you're trying to
figure that one out
I have another question for the audience
by any chance did anyone happen to bring
with them this morning a calculator if
you have a calculator with you and
you're pretty comfortable using it raise
your hand okay I see okay one person
over here and all right how about how
about you that's two and okay three and
four with the four of you join me up on
stage let's give these volunteers a nice
round of applause come on up here over
on this side right one two three
and one more round of applause for our
brave volunteers thank you so much now
since I haven't had the chance to work
with these calculators I need to make
sure that they are all working properly
with somebody get us started by giving
us a two digit number please ma'am how
about a two digit number 67 and another
two digit number
please a two digit number 58 multiply 67
times 58 on your calculator make sure
you get three thousand eight hundred
eighty six or the calculators are not
working do all of you get three thousand
eight hundred eighty six three eight
eight six give them a round of applause
now I notice that took some of you just
a little bit of time to get your answer
that's okay I'll give you a shortcut for
multiplying even faster on the
calculator there's something called the
square of a number which many of you
know is taking a number and multiplying
it by itself for instance five squared
would be 25 smart audience now on most
calculators there there is a shortcut
for doing it oh my gosh you've got some
pretty sophisticated ones that actually
have an x squared button on it for your
calculator you might just do like five
times five equals okay you might have to
do it the long way but what I'm going to
try and do now is to square in my head
for two-digit numbers faster than they
can do on their calculators even using
the shortcut method but I'll ask for
people let's say in the third row this
time one two three four to each yell out
a two-digit number and if you would
square the first number the second the
third and the fourth I will try and race
you to the answer so quickly a two-digit
number please
39 72 96 108 give that would you call
out your answers please 1521 - 72 times
72 108 that's for you what did you get
921 six what do you got five thousand
one hundred eighty four and finally
eleven thousand six sixty four give them
a round of applause
let me try to take this one step further
I'm going to try to square some
three-digit numbers this time I won't
even write these down I'll just call
them out as they're called out to me
anyone I point to call out a three-digit
number anyone on our panel verify the
answer if I get the answer right give me
a thumbs up if I make a mistake let me
know and I'll try and fix it okay a
three-digit number sir three digits 384
squared is one hundred forty-seven
thousand four hundred fifty-six yes good
okay another another another three-digit
number sir 776 776 is 600 2,176 602 176
yes good another another three-digit
number sir 467 467 is 218,000 and 89 to
one eight zero eight nine good another
another another three-digit number go
ahead 614 614 is 376 thousand nine
hundred 96 yes one more three-digit
number please three digits 452 is two
hundred four thousand three hundred and
four thank you very much
let me try to take this one step further
try I will try to square a four-digit
number this time now I'm not going to
beat you to the answer on this one
what's up maybe you but that's okay just
kidding but I will try to get the I will
try to get the answer right to make this
a little bit more random let's take
let's take four people along this aisle
if I can get the first four of you to
call out a single digit between zero and
nine that will be the four digit number
that I'll square go ahead you can say a
single digit please two seven eight nine
whoo two seven eight nine this will take
me a little bit of time so bear with me
seven million seven hundred seventy
eight thousand five hundred twenty-one
good thank you very much
now I would attempt to square a five
digit number and I can but unfortunately
most calculators cannot yours can I'll
talk to you later
I think he's right uh in the meanwhile
let me conclude the first part of my
show by trying something a little
trickier would you choose any one of the
four numbers from the board here not the
last one that's a little too big any of
the first three numbers which would you
like 9216 would you each enter nine two
one six
on your calculator make sure you all
have the correct number to start and
what I want you to do this time is take
that number and multiply it by any
three-digit number that you'd like but
don't tell me what you're multiplying by
just multiply it by any random
three-digit number so you should have as
an answer either a six digit or possibly
probably a seven digit number how many
digits do you have six or seven seven
seven seven seven is there any possible
way that I could know what seven digit
numbers they have say no good then I
shall attempt the impossible or at least
the improbable what I'd like each of you
to do is to call out for me any six of
your seven digits any six of them in any
order you'd like one digit at a time I
shall try and determine the digit you've
left out so starting with your seven
digit number call out any six of them
please did you leave out the number
three good that's one you have a seven
digit number called any six of yours
loud and clear I think you left out the
number one that's two you've got a seven
digit number called any six of them in
any order for six
eight eight four eight I think you left
out the number seven that's three the
odds of me getting all four of these by
pure guessing would be one in 10,000 ten
to the fourth power okay any six of
yours really scramble them up this time
six six two two one one do me a favor if
you would concentrate on the digit you
left out doesn't do any good it just
looks dramatic and yet I'm getting a lot
of nothing did you leave out a zero
because that's why I was getting a lot
of nothing and let's give all four of
these people a nice round of applause
thank you very much thank you
here we go well for my next number I'd
like to present something that we
Mathemagician 'z refer to as magic
squares magic squares are kind of like
pseudo ku on steroids now I have done
such an extensive study on magic squares
that I'd like to create another one for
you right before your very eyes
but for this I'll need another volunteer
somebody here I do not know and let's
see okay I do not know you what's your
name
Piper let's give Piper a nice round of
applause come on up here Piper over on
that side Piper let me see is that
spelled P iper
good my spelling is not always great
Piper I'll ask you another question and
if it's too personal I can change the
question Piper are you willing to share
with us your birthday including the year
good Piper what is your birthday October
5th 10 5 1997 10 5 97 that's your
birthday if we were to add the numbers
in your birthday together Piper let's
see we get 10 plus 5 is 15 plus 9 is 24
plus 7 is 31 so 31 becomes your magic
number now what I'm going to try and do
now Piper is fill out this box in such a
way as to get your magic number
appearing here as much as I possibly can
this will take me a couple of seconds so
bear with me I think that works Piper
would you choose for us any row row
number 2 3 or 4 which would you like 4
okay class together 5 plus 6 is 11 plus
11 is 22 plus 9 is 31 the odds were 10
15 24 31 8 16 25 31 10 20 20 oh my gosh
oh no wait a minute
anyway that adds up to 33 and that is
not good let's see so I know
I did I know what I did I know what I
did I think if I turn this ten into an
eight I'll feel much better okay
8 18 22 31 let's try the columns let's
see how we did there choose a column 1 2
3 or 4 - ok class 5 plus 8 is Oh No
Oh No okay wait a minute I have to I
have to make oh my gosh
I I feel like I've I feel like I'm
letting you down here I'm gonna make two
adjustments as feels really silly but
I'm gonna do it anyway
all right so checking again this row
still adds to 31 this one adds to 31 if
we go down this column we have 30 123
adds up to 5 13 23 31 how about this one
cross our fingers 9 plus 9 is 18 plus 4
is 22 plus 9 is 31 the others were 7 13
22 31
how about that let me try to take this
one step further Piper I decided that
since this was your Magic Square
at no extra charge I would give you
these diagonals as well check it out
here 5 plus 10 is 15 plus 9 is 24 plus 7
is 31 10 18 22 31 but I didn't stop
there either I decided since this was
for Piper wouldn't it be great if we
could get these 4 in the center to add
up as well check it out here 8 plus 9 is
17 plus 4 is 21 plus 10 is 31 but did I
stop there did I stop there no Piper you
may have noticed I put a little extra
attention in that corner I did that so I
could get these four squares 10 plus 5
is 15 plus 8 is 20 3 plus 8 is 31 to add
up and I figured heck as long as we got
that krupa for lots of a party we might
as well get this group of 4 9 16 22 31 8
18 26 31 for 13 22 31 but did I stop
there no I said Piper wouldn't be happy
unless we got this group before this
group before this group before this
group before this group before this
group before I have to apologize Piper I
was not able to get this group of four
nor that group afford to add
up but I had to do it that way if I was
going to get these four in the corners I
knew that would be important to you 9 10
17 26 31 but wait here's the cool part
Piper not only do those four numbers in
the corners add to 31 if you look at
them closely you'll see we have 10 597 I
was able to give you your birthday a
second time I thought you'd like that
so please keep this as a souvenir for me
and let's give Piper a nice round of
applause thank you
Piper very much
hey speaking of birthdays by any chance
does anyone here happen to know the day
of the week that they were born on if
you think you know your actual birthday
raise your hand our starting with you
please
what year if I may 1997 she says and
what month February what February 19th
was that a Wednesday yes good somebody
else yes please what year 97 you said
and the month September September what
30th was that 8 was that a Tuesday
mom says yes good how about all right
let's see how about OK in the against
the wall towards there you yell it out
what year what was that 2002 and what
month September
yes September what six was that a Friday
yes good uh how about let's see do we
have anybody here who does not know
their birthday but would like to know
their birthday all right I'll do this
gentleman here now um
now of course if you don't know what it
is you you wouldn't know if I got it
right so I brought with me just in case
a book of calendars it goes as far back
into the past as 1800 cuz you never know
I didn't mean to look at you and I said
that you're just sitting there uh but
let's see so if I can get if I can get
you to help me out here so to give us
your birthday and together we'll verify
it's day of the week
what year if I may 61 that's a good year
in what month May what 15th I believe
that was a Monday can you it was a
Monday I'll tell you what as long as you
have that book with you do me a favor
turn to a year outside of the 1900s
either in the 1800s or way
- mm that'll be a much greater challenge
for me what year would you like sir 1836
okay and what month November what third
I believe that was a Thursday and it was
cloudy I think thank you very much thank
you
now folks if I were performing for a
different sort of audience like say at
the Magic Castle in Hollywood or
Disneyland or so as I occasionally do I
would follow this up with other feats of
magic and mind but for an audience such
as this one so in the math and science
I actually prefer to break the
magician's rule and explain to you most
of what you've seen me do up here and
more in fact I'd like to conduct the
rest of this program the next 35 minutes
or so very informally so feel free at
any time to interrupt you with questions
even if it has nothing to do with what
I'm talking about
it's more interesting that way but
inevitably the first question is well
okay start explaining how do you
multiply numbers so quickly so let me
start with that one and then I'll take
your questions about anything at all now
I like to do everything by example would
you give us get us started give us a
two-digit number times a one digit
number as our first example a two-digit
number 53 times nine is 477 and here's
how I do it
now if there's only one thing you
remember from this entire presentation
today it should be this I do all of my
calculating from left to right all right
now that's the opposite of how you might
do it on paper on paper most people go
from right to left and that's fine for
doing it on paper but if you want to do
the math in your head like I do and I
say you should do it from left to right
and after all we read numbers from left
to right we pronounce numbers from left
to right we say 53 not three and 50 and
with just a little practice you can
calculate from left to right much
quicker let me show you how we start
with nine times 50 well 9 times 5 is 45
so 9 times 50 is 450 then we do 9 times
3 which is 27 and now we add those
numbers from left to right and we get
477 now it took me about a minute to
explain that but trust me with just a
little bit of practice you can do any
two-digit times one digit number in just
a few seconds it's just a matter of
practice but I know this is a
sophisticated audience so I'm going to
take you up a higher level let's do a
three-digit number times a one digit
number this time how about a three-digit
number sir
125 let's make it even bigger let's uh
they can make it a bigger one 375 okay
times a one digit number eight is 3000
even now I confess that one was a little
easier than normal but I'll show you
what I did anyway I once I started with
eight times 300 which is 2,400 now
normally I do eight times seventy added
to this than eight times five and add it
to that but here I took advantage of
something I know
75 times eight is 600 right I know
eight times 25 is 200 right if you have
eight quarters in your pocket that's two
dollars so eight times 75 is 600 so I
went right to doing that 2,400 plus 600
from left to right is 3000 okay again it
took me about a minute to explain that
and though this was a little bit easier
than normal with just a little practice
you can do any three digit times one
digit number in just a few seconds but
let me show you something I want to show
you something right now that you can do
all of you with almost no practicing
needed we'll start with something very
easy this is especially good for the
youngest members of the audience how to
multiply in your head
the number 11 times any two-digit number
very easy once you know the secret give
us a small two-digit number just to get
started 11 well that's that's almost too
easy because we're multiplying it by 11
how about another one seventeen
okay 17 times 11
is as easy to do as 1 + 7 1 plus 7 is 8
and there's your answer 1 8 7
I told you it was easy here let's do
another one
let's say the problem was let's say the
problem was 62 times 11 6 plus 2 is so
what's the answer
682 you got it all right one more this
time I want to hear everybody give me
the entire answer not just the middle
number as soon as I write it down
tell me 81 times 11 what is it
891 give yourselves a nice round of
applause
now before you get too excited you have
a question about this well so so there's
really two questions why does it work
but also what if you had two numbers
that add it up to something bigger than
nine
suppose we had a problem like Oh 85
times 11 now 8 plus 5 is 13 but the
answer is not 8 13 5 I'm afraid we only
have room for the three but the 1 makes
the 8 carry and the answer is oh you
guys are on top of this right 935 here
let's do another one let's say the
problem was Oh 57 times 11 5 plus 7 is
12 so what's the answer
627 you got it all right one more this
time I want to hear everybody give me
the entire answer as soon as I count to
3 so when I say 3 and not before I want
everyone to yell out the answer to 77
times 11 1 2 3
you kids are smart give yourselves
another nice round of applause nice job
let me see let me show you something
else I mean that's really pretty easy
let me show you something that's just a
little bit more difficult but with
practice you can all do these quickly
you saw me earlier in the show running
around the room squaring numbers two
digit numbers three digit numbers and
higher let me show you the method that I
use for squaring two-digit numbers and
if you're interested we can move it up
to higher numbers as well I like to do
everything by example give us a small
two-digit number as our first example go
ahead 25 actually owl um all right I'll
do 25 that one's really easy numbers it
end in fact let me say that as my second
example let's another small two-digit
number how about another one this time
37 that's a little harder but we'll do
it now 37 is not a bad number to
multiply but what number close to 37 is
much easier 40 so I'm going to go up 3
to the number 40 now whatever comes up
must come down if I go up 3 to 40 I have
to go down to the same day the same
distance to the number 34 so the first
part of my calculation is I do 40 times
34 now don't panic that's just 4 times
34 with a friendly 0 attached
I like zeros let's do 4 times 34
together really together 4 times 30 is
say it 120 4 times 4 is say it 16 120
Plus 16 added from left to right 120
plus 16 is good 136 now we bring in the
friendly 0 that's 1360 and we're almost
done all we have to add to this is the
square of the number that we went up and
down you went up and down 3 3 squared is
9 and there's your answer
1369 not bad here let's do another let's
do another let's do 25 ok
numbers that end in 5 are especially
easy because
time I'll go down five to the number 20
therefore we go up to what number thirty
all right because if I go down five I
have to go up five 20 times 30 is 600
and what do we add to that yeah the
square of 5 which is 25 to get say it
625 you got it
all right all right now it's your turn
I'll give you a problem to do and we'll
see we'll see who can get the answer
first now to make it to make it a little
bit more interesting I brought along
with me one of my DVD courses to the
first mathemagics for the first person
who can get this answer right now I know
technically I should give it to the last
person who gets the answer right but
that would take too long ok so when you
think you have it raise your hand but no
talking no whispering no paper even I
want you to do this in your head and no
calculators ok I got a couple whiz kids
in the front who probably shouldn't
participate here but will here we go so
when you think you have the answer raise
your hand I want to see who can square
the number 97 97 you think you've got it
all right
okay give a few people a chance to raise
their hand I see a bunch okay I think I
saw your hand up first sir what do you
get what was that again no that wasn't
it um what did sir would you get nine
thousand four hundred and nine give him
a round of applause
and yep this is for you you don't have
one of these already do you know okay
now you do so what you did I hope was
you went up three to a hundred down
three to ninety four ninety four times a
hundred is ninety four hundred plus the
square of three which is nine to get
nine thousand four hundred and nine well
done give another round of applause
very good well like I said I have hours
and hours of stuff that I could show you
but only about another 20 25 minutes
left so I want to spend that time
talking about whatever is of interest to
you so I see this as a very high energy
inquisitive audience what is it that you
are interested in knowing I think I saw
your hand up first sir so you have the
first question
well can I do some tricks with the
golden ratio I'll tell you what I
actually can I know we have the audience
saying what the heck is a golden ratio
let me let me try something here and see
how how this works out okay
so now if you have a calculator in the
audience go ahead and bring it out I'll
get and alright so I've got a chart here
numbered 1 through 10 and let me ask me
ask somebody to give me a number give me
a number between 1 and 20 yeah what pick
a number from 1 to 20 17 okay and
another number from 1 to 20 how about
you yeah 12 okay so with so with those
with calculators can verify this as we
go along so I'm going to take 17 and 12
add them together to get 29 then I'm
going to do 12 plus 29 to get 41 and
then 29 plus 41 to
seventy and I'm going to continue
writing the numbers all the way through
these first ten now if you have a
calculator what I want you to actually
do is add up all the numbers in row one
through row ten okay so I'm going to
keep on doing this 70 plus 41 is 111 111
plus 70 is 181 292 and 473 and 765 and
if you add all those numbers together
you know what you're going to get I'll
tell you
1991 anybody with a calculator can
confirm that that's correct 1991 I'll
show you how that works later but here's
the part that has to do with the golden
ratio if you take with your calculator
the last number on the board 765 divide
it by the number before that 473 okay so
if you take 765 divided by 473 who had
with the calculator call out the call
out the and the first three digits of
the answer go ahead sir what do you have
one point six one which happens to be
the golden ratio thank you very much
so what was that how does that work
that's a great question because that's
what I am looking for as a professional
mathematician as a math teacher I'm a
professor of mathematics at Harvey Mudd
College in Claremont California and I
wouldn't be doing my job if I didn't
actually try to explain this stuff to
you and so so let me let me show you
briefly what's going on all right so if
I don't know that the first number can
be any number let's just call that
number X okay and the next number can be
any number let's call it Y if we add
those numbers together we get X plus y
add those numbers together even if
you're rusty on your algebra you should
be able to get X plus 2y and so on if we
fill out the rest of this chart then
these are the numbers you get if you
look at the coefficients the numbers
behind the X's and the Y's you actually
have my favorite numbers you know what
they are the Fibonacci numbers and if
you add all those numbers together
algebraically then what you get the
total is 55 X plus 88 y let me write
that in a darker marker 55 X 3d effect
plus 88 Y now how do I calculate the
total so quickly I'm not actually doing
55 times 17 plus 88 times 12 I'm not
doing that in my head but can somebody
tell me what 55 and 88 have in common
yeah they're multiples of 11 so this is
the same as 11 times 5x plus 8y now
what's 5x plus 8y why is that
is that going to help me here does
anybody see 5 X + 8 y on the board you
might not be able to see it but it
actually happens to be row number 7 so
what I'm doing to add all those numbers
together is I'm taking 11 times row 7
now row 7 here happens to be 181 and
here's another way to multiply by 11
it's a three-digit number but it's going
to begin with a one end with a 1 1 plus
8 is 9 and 8 plus 1 is 9 and that's how
you get 1 9 9 1 the total let's hear it
for algebra
now as to row ten divided by row nine
and how we get let's see that's 21 x +
34 y / 13 X plus 21y I will just say
it's all about I won't go into all the
algebra here but this is going to lie in
between the fractions 21 over 13 and the
fraction 34 over 21 no matter what x and
y are as long as they're positive then
we're going to have this number is going
to lie between 21 over 13 and 34 over 21
and that happens to be about one point
six one something one point six one five
something and this happens to be like
one point six one nine something so
whatever you have in the middle has to
lie between those those two numbers and
in either case you're going to start
with one point six one thank you very
much good question
all right I love talking about Fibonacci
numbers golden ratio I've written a book
on the subject that's just one of my
favorite things to to do real
mathematics with other questions yes sir
what's your question okay so you saw me
do two-digit numbers times one digit
numbers you saw me two two-digit numbers
times themselves but what if we were
multiplying two different two-digit
numbers that's where it gets interesting
for me because I always square numbers
the same way but when I when it comes to
multiplying different two-digit numbers
I have to get creative I have to look
for patterns which I can take advantage
of I've always enjoyed looking for
patterns let's do an example
give us a give us a two-digit number
please
47 okay and how about another two-digit
number please
what was that 89 that's actually a very
tricky one but I'll tell you what the
answer is it's four thousand one hundred
eighty three and I'll tell you how I do
that now I always know this problem
happened to be much harder than usual
because forty-seven and eighty-nine what
kind of numbers are they good prime
numbers that means I can't factor them I
can't pull them apart and make them
smaller numbers and that's my preference
if I can do like if you had said 48
times 89 instead
Hewitt's had 48 times 89 then what I
would have done was I would I would have
taken a 48 and written that as eight
times six and then all I'd have to do
would be 89 times eight times six and
since we know how to do a two-digit
number times a one digit number 640 plus
72 is seven hundred twelve times six and
then I could do six times seven hundred
forty-two hundred six times twelve 72 to
get
- but you didn't give me 48 so I had to
try and take advantage of something else
and so here I took advantage the best
thing I could come up with was 89 if you
were to really multiply something by 89
and you wanted an approximation what
would you multiply instead 90 so 89 is
90 minus 1 so I started by doing 90
times 47 and that's 9 times 47 with a 0
on it so that's four thousand two
hundred thirty and then I have to
subtract 1 times 89 I have to subtract
89 and I'll tell you what Oh dice did I
do that right did I actually give the
wrong answer there it would appear that
I it would appear that I gave the wrong
and I will wait wait wait a second here
40 I'm sorry I just packed 1 times 47
thank you so I subtract I do 80 90 times
47 minus 1 times 47 so I'm gonna
subtract 47 now here's what goes on in
my head I have 4,200 30 minus 47 47 is
bigger than 30 so I know that the answer
is going to begin how 40 100 and
something by the way let me pause to say
this is another reason why it's good to
work from left to right by going from
left to right I can start to say my
answer while I'm still calculating
giving the illusion that I'm doing the
problem even faster than I am and that's
a good thing also it allows me to free
up memory space I can take after I say
4100 I can forget about it and then all
I have to concentrate on is 30 minus 47
now that seems hard but what the
opposite problem is easy
what's 47 minus 30 17 I then take what's
called the complement of 17 to get 83
that's the number which one added those
numbers together gives you a hundred so
I so the way I really did 30 minus 47 is
I see 17 and it's compliment is 83 and
that's how we get four thousand one
hundred eighty three isn't that more
interesting I think so
for me it's where it's where the fun
begins yes sir what's your question do I
do anything with square roots well there
are two types of square root problems
out there
you can either it could either be a
perfect square like on your calculator
you take a two-digit number you square
it and I tell you what the original
number is that you can do by a process
of elimination or you if it's not a
perfect square then of course I can't
rattle off the entire answer that
literally would go on forever but the
best I can do is come up with an
approximation and the way I do the
approximation is by something called
divide and average let me give you an
example if you have a calculator bring
it out take us give me a three digit
number and I'll give you or a two digit
number and I'll give you an approximate
square root what was that was that 77 to
77 ah okay so 277 now I happen to know
17 squared is 280 now well that's not
going to help me okay so um all right so
I was thinking 287 okay 277 so here's
how we here's how we do divide and
average I'll start by dividing it by a
real easy number like let's say 10 and
10 goes into 277 how many times
twenty-seven point seven so 10 times 27
going 7 is exactly 277 that means 10
times 10 would be way too low and 27.7
times itself would be way too high the
answer the square root has to lie
somewhere in between so I take these two
numbers and average them so I have 37 so
10 plus 27 point
seven / - I always take 30 so that's
about 37 over 2.7 that's about 18 okay
so so I could take 18 as a guess now if
I want to do if I want to get a better
guess than 18 which isn't really that
close
I'll take 18 and divide that into 277
now let's see 18 I'll do I know 18 times
15 is 270 so 18 times 15 is 270 with a
remainder of 7 so the answer lies
somewhere between 18 and 15 roughly 15
and a half so I take 18 plus 15 and a
half even though it's more like 15 point
4 divide that by 2 so that's 33 point 4
over 2 which is about 16 point seven so
that would be my estimate for the square
root that it would be somewhere that
dividing average is always a little bit
high so I'd say it's a little bit less
than sixteen point seven what's the
actual number sixteen point six four and
there's your answer
thank you
but it's not part of my normal
repertoire because unlike this audience
many audiences out there don't even know
what a square root is much less how to
calculate it yes please what's your
question how did I do the card track
that's what you really want to know all
right if everybody asks me at the same
time how'd you do it I did it very well
huh that's the only part of my show I
won't reveal especially while we're
being televised I would get kicked out
of the magician's Union and the Magic
Castle if I taught you that one so
anything else anything else I'm happy to
reveal got maybe time for one or two
more questions all right you see me very
well you know you know what you know
what III don't want to I don't want to
run out of time before showing you
something else I have to do this before
before the this event I got an email
from a young man who who had just
started learning my techniques he read
my book secrets of mental math just a
few months ago and he was very excited
about it and he actually developed his
talents and participated in a talent
show in his elementary school let me
introduce to you my new friend ten year
old Ethan brown Ethan would you come on
up here
Ethan if you would stand right there
give you the mic Ethan is amazing and
let me let I wanna oh yeah you said just
three months ago when you started doing
okay
so here we go so I asked somebody for it
and I won't stay away from Ethan's
parents here somebody for a two-digit
number how about a how about give a go
ahead and give us a two-digit number 87
woo that's strictly Ethan can you square
87 I'll block his view 7500 69
Ethan are you up for a three-digit
number it might take me a little bit of
time all right let I can get it let's
try all right how about how about Ethan
can you square 312 96 thousand seven
hundred forty-four I'm going to give you
one more chance on that one try on 312
just so you know we didn't set this up
ninety seven thousand three hundred
forty-four give him around
I may be pushing my luck but let's try a
bigger one Ethan try try and square try
and square 987 974 thousand one hundred
sixty-nine give him a round of applause
was fast
all right all right who wants who wants
to know their birthday I wanna say okay
I saw your hand up so what what year
1997 and what month August what August
27 was that a Wednesday it sure was
let's give Ethan a nice round of
applause congratulations that was great
I gotta tell you I I see this and I just
get all choked up I mean this is really
this is really what what my my goal in
life is to spread math to folks like
Ethan and like all of you so that you in
this point is not to see how smart I am
up here is to see how smart you can be
any of you can do what you're seeing up
here with just a little bit of practice
let me let me wrap things up by doing
one last thing for you that I alluded to
earlier when we only well we had some
people on stage who had I see you're
flashing your calculator a ten digit
calculator if you've got a calculator
that will handle ten digits or more you
may bring it out I'm going to try to
square a five digit number five digit
number but to make my job more
interesting for you as well as for me
I'm going to I'm going to do this last
problem thinking out loud so you can
actually honestly hear what's going on
in my mind while I do a calculation of
this size now let's create a five digit
number I'll go up this aisle here but I
can get the first five of you to call
out a single digit that will be the five
digit number that I'll square go ahead
eight two six nine haha 78 thousand two
hundred sixty nine squared yuck
might even be Prime I don't know let me
show you how I'm going to attempt this
problem I'm going to break the problem
down into three parts I'll do 78,000
squared plus 269 squared plus 78
thousand times to 69 times to add all
those numbers together and with any luck
arrive at the answer now let me recap
thank you while I explain something else
as I do this last calculation you might
hear certain words as opposed to numbers
creep into the calculation let me
explain what that is this is a phonetic
code a mnemonic device that I use that
allows me to convert numbers into words
I store them as words and later on
retrieve them as numbers I know it
sounds complicated it's not I just don't
want you to think you're seeing
something out of Rain Man here there's
definitely a method to my madness
definitely definitely sorry one last
instruction for my judges with
calculators now you should have a ten
digit answer probably begins with a six
and ends with a one in between I don't
know there is at least a 50% chance that
I'll make a mistake somewhere in the
middle if I do don't tell me what the
mistake is just say you're close or
something and I'll try and figure it out
which can be pretty entertaining in
itself if however I am right whatever
you do don't keep it to yourselves all
right make sure everybody knows that I
got the answer right because this is my
Big Finish
if you have an answer in front of you
raise your hand just so I see where okay
a bunch of you out there great umm I'll
even tell you one more detail that I
normally normally don't reveal I'll tell
you how I'm going to do 78 times to 69
to 69 is prime but it's one less than
270 which is very composite and I'll
take advantage of that okay so without
any more stalling here we go I'll start
the problem in the middle with 78 times
269 knots to it 270 is 27 is 9 times 3
78 times 9 is 700 2 times 3 is 21 Oh 6
has 21,000 and 60 21,000 and 60 minus 78
is 20,000 compliment 982 20,000 982
double that to get 41,000 864 41,000 864
becomes right Fisher right Fisher is
41,000 864 that seems that seems wrong
actually I'm going to try that one again
so I get one more time I get 2106 that's
21 72 2106 20 1060 20 1060 subtract the
78 I'm getting 20,000 982 double that to
get 4d I'm worried about this here 4000
I got at 41,000 964 there we go 41,000
964 becomes right pitcher right pitcher
I think that works for the right pitcher
okay next I do 78 squared which is 6,000
84 so I can say six billion take the 84
add that to right 84 plus 41 is 125 but
I see a carry so it's 126 million
pitcher pitcher no yet not yet
pitcher pitcher next I dune to 69
squared that's 300 times 238 plus 31
squared seventy one thousand four
hundred plus nine 61 to 72 thousand 360
one machete if I need it machete take
the 72 add that to pitcher to get 36
thousand three hundred sixty one yes
good thank you very much
I hope you enjoyed mathemagics thank you